Thank You Shafie for that introduction
and thank you everyone for coming I I
think I'll start by giving you a brief
overview of what to expect this evening
we have a very distinguished panel with
us so let me start by first telling you
who they are briefly and then I'll do a
detailed introduction for each panelist
when they get up to speak about their
work so there is we have professor
Celeste Cade she is professor of
psychology at UC Berkeley a professor
Bruno Olhausen neuroscientist at UC
Berkeley Michael Pollan was a professor
UC Berkeley Graduate School of
Journalism and also for the purposes of
this evening author of how to change
your mind and then we have professor
christos papadimitriou he's a computer
scientist from Columbia University who's
just flown in from New York so I will
tell you more about each panelist in a
little bit but what I want to do is just
give you a sense of what to expect this
evening we will start with each panelist
speaking briefly 5 to 7 minutes about
their work as it pertains to the topic
of this evening which is the predictive
brain and I'll come to what we mean by
the predictive brain in a moment and
then once each panelist is done giving
us an introduction to their research in
the context of the predictive brain we
will have a Q&A session amongst the
panelists which I will help moderate and
then once we're done with that
discussion then we'll open the floor to
questions from the audience so that's
kind of the structure of the evening and
it would be lovely if you have questions
that come up in your mind to just wait
until we get to the last 20 minutes 25
minutes so that we can get you the mics
and you can you know speak into the mic
I think this is getting recorded so yeah
so that's the structure of the evening
and what are we here this evening for
we're basically trying to ask this
question and try and understand how does
the brain perceive there's a
neuroscientist in the
okay he's a namesake of mine his name is
Anil Seth who has a very lovely way of
illustrating this problem and I'm going
to steal his words so imagine the
quandary of being a brain imagine the
problem of being a brain this
three-pound mass of tissue is stuck
inside a bony skull with a few holes
from which there's information coming in
from the outside and from within your
body and it has to make sense of this
information and create a really vivid
perceptual experience that each one of
us right now is having so how did how is
that possible and that's a really big
question in neuroscience and and one of
the ways in which you can think the
brain might be doing this is by saying
okay maybe it's just getting all the
information in and somehow from the
bottom up constructing this percept that
you know so the information that is
coming in is rich with details and it's
somehow extracting all those details and
constructing a perception of the world
that you're in and also of your own body
it turns out that this is not quite how
the brain might be doing it because it's
and I think Bruno we'll get to why this
might be and not the way to think about
how the brain creates perceptions over
the last two or three decades there has
been a shift in thinking about how the
brain might be creating perceptions and
this is the topic of the evening it's
the idea that it's an idea that actually
goes back a long way all the way to
Plato then Kant and then most
significantly to a 19th century German
physiologist called Hermann on Helmholtz
Helmholtz basically argued that the way
the brain creates perceptions is by
based it's by making inferences about
the most likely cause of the inputs that
are falling on your eyes and ears and
body so it's essentially trying to
predict what might be the cause of the
inputs that you're receiving right so
this is what we mean by prediction by
prediction we are not saying that we are
predicting the future the brain is
basically taking a certain set of
information prior information
it has about the world outside and about
the body and then he uses that
information to make a probabilistic
judgment about what might be the cause
of the inputs that are falling on your
eyes your ears your skin etc so and
that's essentially the topic that we're
going to dig into throughout the course
of this evening that that perception is
an act of inference it's it's an
inference about the most likely most
probable cause of the inputs that you're
receiving and if all this sounds a bit
esoteric I want to play a little game
with you and this will really illustrate
how amazing this concept is so there are
two examples in each example there are
three audio clips the first clip that
you will hear is something called a sine
wave speech it is a degraded form of an
actual snippet of sound and when you
hear it it won't sound like anything at
all except just a series of beeps and
tones it will actually sound like r2d2
and then the next clip that we'll play
is the actual speech from which this
degraded waveform was created right so
you will hear what the speech is and
then we'll play the degraded waveform
all over again
and I want you to pay attention to what
you perceive when the degraded waveform
is played all over again so hoping this
works now so this will be the first
degraded speech how many of you figured
out what that was okay somebody has got
a very good ear but okay this is the
actual sound actually it was a sunny day
and the children were going to the park
right did everyone hear what we'll ask
her later let me let me get through we
have a lot of no lotta stuff to get
through and we'll come back to questions
keep keep that in mind and keep yeah
yeah you remember it so and another
example right so this is anyone okay
this time no one thank God okay
all right here's the sitting at his desk
in his office so what happened when he
heard the degraded speech both times the
input waveform falling on your ears is
exactly the same there's no more or no
less information but something changed
when you heard the speech and that
change happen in your brain so there was
a before you heard the actual speech
there was no prior information about
what that speech was and then your
brains prior information about what
you're gonna hear changed and then now
it was able to predict what is the most
likely cause of the waveform that you
just heard right so this is a this was
an example of something that the brain
is doing it's predicting and and we're
going to now get stuck into this
hopefully quite a lot so I would I'm
going to start by introducing you to
Bruno and so Bruno Olhausen is a
professor in the Helen Wills
Neuroscience Institute and School of
Optometry he also directs the Redwood
centre for theoretical neuroscience
which is a multidisciplinary research
group focusing on building mathematical
and computational models of brain
function bruno started as an engineer
wanting to build robots inspired by how
brains work bruno have stolen this from
your website and ended up as a
neuroscientist attempting to understand
how nervous systems process information
inspired and guided by
during principals his research is
focused on understanding how the brain
builds representations of 3d surfaces
material properties objects and motion
from the voltage fluctuations of
photoreceptors in the retina somehow
Nature has figured out a solution to
this daunting problem and Runa wants to
reverse engineer nature solution to
solve this puzzle so so I think I'd like
to just make two main points to start
off with the first is that one of the
biggest myths of visual perception is
that what you experience in perception
is just the image at the back of your
eye the retinal image and the second is
that what you do perceive is a story
that's conjured by your brain and it's
essentially an internal model of the
world that you build in order to
function in the world to reason about it
to plan actions and so forth and this is
something that your brain brain
constructs and it's not constantly
making predictions about the sensory
input and using the police predictions
the match or mismatch between these
predictions to help build up this model
the world and so I'll try to make this
point through two specific examples one
is the perception of stability in the
face of moving images on the retina and
the second is the the inference of very
detailed three-dimensional structure
from ambiguous figures which is kind of
like the visual analogue of wood and
you'll just show you for sound so let's
go to the first so the first is just
this good but the image shows here is a
depiction of the cones in your eye in
the retina this is from Austin weirdest
lab where they have the technology to be
able actually see through the living
human eye and image individual accounts
each one of those dots as a cone you can
say think of these essentially as the
pixels of the camera in your eye and so
what you can see it's kind of grainy
they're kind of irregularly spaced but
what's even more dramatic is what
happens when you when you look at some
object in the world so when you so when
you look at an object its constant your
eye is constantly moving so even though
you're trying to hold your eyes still
there's this constant drip that's
happening there in
in the eye and so the size of this
letter here this e is about the same
size as the letters on the lowest row of
snow and ice charts when you look at the
eye chart and the eye doctors office
right and those letters in the lowest
row you could read if you have 20/20
vision and this is how big they would
appear on the retina so what's really
remarkable about this is that when you
when you're looking at this as the
subject that II does not appear to be
moving okay it looks like it's rock
solid and stable in the world and the
second remarkable thing is that you can
read the e right you can you can make
sense of it even though the structure on
which it's defined is on the same scale
this cone of the cones there so another
way of thinking about this is that you
know you're not aware of the pixels here
in your retina you can't see the pixels
and you can't see the motion so one
thing that neuroscientists kind of
debate and think about a lot is is this
you know aspect of fixation is this a
feature or is it a buck is this just
because of you know poor design and
biology or is it a good thing and we
actually think it's a good thing the
brain that the visual system does this
for for a reason and it actually helps
you build a higher acuity representation
a model an internal model of what's
going on the world even though the
internal the data coming in it's even
noisier than this because that data is
coming in the form of spikes or action
potentials which are sort of punctate
all or nothing sort of digital events
coming in through the optic nerve okay
so so so the so to do this we actually
we have constructed a mathematical model
based on Bayesian inference so it's
essentially a mathematical model that
tries to construct some kind of internal
estimate of what's going on out there in
the world based on all these spikes
coming in from the eye and this is the
work of alexanderson who is a PhD
student in my lab and so the and so this
is what something's shown here as a
graphical model okay so it may be we
have to point a few things from here but
so it's constructed as a graphical model
and what's coming in from your eye are
these things are that stands for the
spike right the spiking neuron responses
that are coming from the eye on time is
going from left to right here and what
your brain is trying to estimate is the
pattern on there on the retina so what
you're looking at and that's assumed to
be constant you're assuming that there
are some shape there that's not changing
in the world and you're trying to
estimate though what that is from these
noisy kind of unstable spikes happening
at the same time you have to estimate
the motion so you trying to track this
thing how it's moving for those of you
familiar with common filters from
engineering which are also based on
Bayesian inference this is not unlike
that is a similar kind of inferential
process okay so what this is just
showing then a simulation of that
process happening so
okay so so it's just a simulation of
this process happening what we're
simulating we're going to simulate here
in E moving across your cone awright so
kind of an irregularly spaced array of
cones and by the way I forgot to mention
one reason why we think this is good is
because it allows your brain to average
over the idiosyncrasies in your in your
cone lattice so each of those cones has
different game factors they have
different wavelengths selectivities and
so if you didn't do this then the e
would it sort of appear differently
depending on where it lands and which
cones it lands on the retina so the idea
is by moving it across the retina you
can actually sort of average across as
appearance and it's habit in a
higher-quality estimate so that's what
you're gonna see here in this animation
is just a simulation of that moving
across what's being shown here in the
middle panel are that as a simulation
the spikes coming in from your retina
from from the on cells and from the off
cells so this is what your brain gets to
look at this is the data that's coming
in okay so it's not like if there's a
homunculus in your brain it's like like
the homunculus can kind of just look at
the spikes and tell what's going on
right it has to make an inference based
okay and so what and that what's being
shown here is an estimate of the pattern
this is sort of your internal model of
what you think is going on and you're
building this up by simultaneously
estimating the motion that's being shown
here on the right tracking the motion
building up this estimate and the same
time making this estimate the pattern
okay and so essentially you're kind of
pulling two rabbits out of a hat you
know just from these spikes you're
estimating these but these two things
simultaneously and using one-to-one to
infer the other so what this does is it
gives us gives us a it gives us a model
that allows us to understand then why it
is so that you know acuity actually does
improve from moving stimuli across the
retina that's been shown in experiments
in Austin's lab that moving a stimulus
actually helps you and that and it and
it helps you out even more when you have
cone loss so there's some subjects that
have as many of 50 as many a 50% of
their cones missing and they actually
have normal visual acuity
okay this gives us a way of reasoning
about how that can be because if the eye
is constantly in motion uptakes allows
the object to sort of move in and out of
these zones of bad pixels and good
pixels so if you just sort of planted
the e in one location this is what you
would get but if you're to move it
across and track it and average this
appearance then you can build upon much
higher quality percent okay so the
summons second demonstration I wanted
is the inference of 3d shape from
ambiguous images so these are what
people used to call puzzle pictures and
you notice we have there's a there's an
object of some form here and for those
of you who seen this before please be
quiet don't say what you think it is so
for those of you have not seen before
this before then this will probably just
look like a bunch of black and white
splotches in the image and one way of
Taric interrogating you you're
interrogating your brain about what you
see is to ask you to draw it and so if
we ask a subject to draw what they see
this is when what one particular person
drew which is simply the outline of the
sort of black and white reasons and the
scene so how many of you would would
draw something like this I've asked to
kind of represent you know what was what
was there okay so good fraction of you
okay
and so now I'm gonna tell you what's
there it's a cow once I've told you this
it will completely destroy you know
you'll never be able to see it like you
saw it the rest of your life okay so
it's a cow and and so there's an eye
here there's an eye here this is the
snout this is the head of the cow okay
so now hopefully a lot of you see it so
now you take the same subject and ask
them to draw what they see and this is
what they draw okay so the question is
where did this come from it came from
inside your head right this is what's
actually on your retina this is the data
that's coming in this is all the right
you have to see I mean you have no right
to say this just based on the day right
you're just you're just creating a story
right you're going we're extrapolating
way beyond the data it's not that you
just see the 2d outline the cow you can
sort of perceive all kinds of aspects
the three-dimensional structure of this
scene for example you can tell that's
sort of an indented part of the nose
here you know the three-dimensional
structure the snout perhaps you know
that the head here isn't part of the
body the body's kind of the background
moreover the graininess here you would
probably a tribute to a photographic
process something in front of the scene
not part of the cow itself I can
separate across all these different
layers so there's an enormous amount of
detail and richness in this scene and
the last question I'm gonna sort of
leave you with is where it where is this
inside your head it's inside all these
different boxes
and these are these these boxes are
basically a depiction of the 30 or so
different visual areas you have in your
visual cortex and what's kind of
remarkable to think about here is that
these boxes here are huge but this is
not where the cow itself lives and sense
of light the identity of the cow what we
know from neuroscience is that these are
sort of more related to image properties
and the sort of abstract notion the cow
is kind of up here and the details are
kind of down here the details you see in
the instance and I think what's very
important to convey this is sort of in
contrast to deep learning architectures
where in those kind of architectures all
of this is in service of the top box and
I think the way we work is that the
representation of what you've seen in
given instance is really distributed
hierarchically across all these layers
and it's in a sense all these together
that constitute your purse up in the
scene all right
so next we have professors les skip
Celeste is assistant professor in the
Department of Psychology at UC Berkeley
she has a PhD in brain and cognitive
sciences from the University of
Rochester and BA is in both linguistics
and journalism she came to Berkeley
after research stints at Rochester
Stanford in MIT she studies processes
involved in knowledge acquisition
especially in young children using a
combination of computational and
behavioral methods her lab designs
behavioral experiments to empirically
differentiate between competing theories
of how humans particularly babies learn
by measuring how learners pay attention
and explore throughout the process of
learning Celeste work has been featured
widely in the media including the New
Yorker
she was Time magazine's Person of the
Year in 2017 a collective honor that was
given to the quote/unquote silence
breakers women and men who spoke out
against sexual harassment and launched a
movement and Celeste will speak about
some aspects of the predictive brain
from the perspective of a developing
mind that's right in Bruno's terms I'm
gonna talk about where the cow comes
from so um that that was that was a nice
segue because a lot of the work that we
do in our lab us because with infants so
it's like infants are born into the
world not knowing about the existence of
things like cows and a mystery is how
they go from knowing very little about
what exists in the world you need to
know what exist in the world in order to
make predictions we know that it's an
important part of perception to have
concepts like cows so the question is
where where does that come from
and one widely believed in theory is
that babies possess a very simple but
very powerful mechanism for learning
things that don't start as complex as
cows but build up to become as complex
as cows babies into the world with the
ability to track co-occurrence
statistics or statistical regularities
and they can use those in order to make
sense of the world down
I want to talk about a great example of
this that helped convince everybody like
that this is how babies are operating
and that's worked by Jenny Safran and
two of her colleagues dick Aslan and
listen Newports they were interested in
how infants solve a particular problem
that problem was speech segmentation we
are all in this room probably as I come
to this talk pretty good language users
at this point so it might not be an
obvious problem but speech when you are
hearing it has a property that's easy to
overlook once you were fluent but that a
baby has to figure out which is that
it's continuous so it's like there's no
breaks between the words unlike words
that are on a written page so they we're
interested in how babies go from this
continuous stream of speech to
eventually knowing where the words are
which is the first step that they need
to solve in order to learn everything
else about the language to learn the
grammar or to learn what what the word
these cells refer to so they had an idea
which is maybe babies are using the
statistical regularities and speech
dreams in order to solve this task if
you consider a phrase like like pretty
baby a baby that doesn't have any
experience with language doesn't know
from just that sequence of syllables
where the words are I was like or even
how many there are that could be four
words that could be one word or anything
anything in between but if you listen to
more language and you're tracking the
statistics across the syllables you can
do something really cool so you consider
these these these four four utterances
maybe a baby hears pretty mama and
pretty kitty and starts to notice you
know when I hear prayer tea is very
likely to follow that sort of moves as a
unit maybe that's where one word is the
baby keeps listening and hears things
like happy baby silly baby i notices
that baby also seems to track as a unit
and maybe that's how they break into to
solving this problem
so to test this they created a nonsense
language that looks something like this
it's hard to make sense of my first
glance some so I'll tell you a little
bit about how they constructed it they
made up novel words that were these
three syllable units and then they
played this four four seven and eight
month old infants for just two minutes
and what they wanted to know is if
babies are able to track the statistics
across these syllables will they notice
where the units are will they notice
what syllables move together and sure
enough I was like as the babies were
able to show that they treated these two
different types of units from the
sequence differently the things that
tracked together the words they they
were less interested in those sounds
like they were most interested in these
part words which is consistent with an
account where those things were
unexpected I was like they had learned
in just two minutes
that from this you know I was like a
stream that seems like nonsense to us
what moves together and what doesn't so
this was some of the first and I think
still some of the most powerful evidence
that infants are capable of tracking
statistics in the world and using those
for gaining high level concepts like
where the words are there's more though
I was like a few years later Joseph Iser
and dick Aslan did some similar work to
see whether infants could employ that
same statistical learning mechanism in
order to learn not just about auditory
sequences but visual visual information
they did an experiment that was very
similar in except instead of having a
lexicon of auditory units they were
visual units that moved around and in
this visual scene with just a few
minutes of exposure again infants
demonstrated that they knew which shapes
moved together and which shapes did not
they form sort of a mini lexicon of
these these visual sequences one last
piece of evidence that I think is very
powerful for showing the importance of
co-occurring statistics and how you can
get very rich inferences from this very
simple mechanism
there's there some work by Scott Johnson
that shows that babies also track
co-occurrence and use that to form
high-level concepts
for things that involve movement so if
you consider a display like this let's
see if I can make it move adults
probably all of you have the intuition
about what what shape is behind that
excluding bar right there you are
generating a prediction about what that
is with partial information I was like
you can't see behind that blue bar so uh
Scott Johnson wanted to know whether
infants could do that it could be that
there's one solid bar that's what most
adults think but it also could be that
there are two bars that just by some
incredible coincidence are moving at
exactly the same right in exactly the
same way and if you test three month
olds expectations you'll find that they
don't have that same bias that you have
they do not always expect that there's a
solid bar sometimes they expect that it
is two pieces but by four months or five
months it's like they've generated the
same adult like representations
presumably by tracking any statistics um
so hopefully I was like I introduced you
to the concept of statistical learning
it's a very powerful domain general
learning mechanism that could
potentially explain how infants learn
everything from words object properties
up to high level more sophisticated
concepts like counts and that's that's
very important because although the
mechanism is simple as a distracting
statistics across things it builds so
initially you can use statistical
learning in order to figure out that the
world word Apple is a unit that moves
together but you can use that same
mechanism in order to solve the next
level of problem which is once you know
that there is a word Apple you have to
figure out what in the world is an apple
cause you have to solve the mapping
problem so noticing co-occurrence
statistics between a spoken word and
what is visually presents is one of the
mechanisms
know that infants employed in this task
and you do that you keep building you
learn more sophisticated properties like
who likes apples and who doesn't
also through similar mechanisms and
eventually you get things like cows yeah
so I was like I was very hand wavy on
that part I assume you guys are gonna
solve in between that slide in this one
you guys got it right a point I wanna I
want to wrap up on this is not just an
important mechanism for understanding
how kids make expectations about things
that exist in the world but also for
understanding how they generate
expectations about where they should go
for learning that's the topic that my
lab works on primarily kids have an
incredible task ahead of them they have
to go from knowing nothing to knowing
all of the stuff that you know right now
and that process involves making
predictions about where you are going to
learn the best we know that that's
something that infants do I think
there's a tendency to think of them as
sort of passive sponges especially when
you when you own one you're worried
about putting exactly the right thing in
front of them you don't you don't have
to have that worry at least there's like
there's lots of other worries like them
choking that you can focus on that's a
real one baby babies are born with all
sorts of very sophisticated mechanisms
for not just generating expectations
about what's an Apple but also figuring
out where they can make the best use of
their time we know that they generate
expectations about the statistical
properties of the world and possibly the
most important thing that they use that
for is deciding where they're gonna look
and where they're not I was like what
toy they're gonna pick up and play with
and which one they're not who they're
going to play with and who they're not
and then eventually who they're gonna
lecture which lecture they're gonna
listen to it which one they're gonna
fall asleep in well thank you thank you
so so maybe at this point something is
becoming clear right when our brains are
making predictions about the likely
causes of sensory inputs in order to
create perceptions they are relying on
internal representations of the outside
world and of the body and these internal
representations might be coming about
you know hardwired like potentially this
you know ability to figure out the
statistics is some sort of ability
that's already there in infants but then
that is being used to build more
sophisticated representations of the
outside world
and and sometimes these representations
can be wrong or sometimes these
predictions can go wrong and that's kind
of leading us to our next speaker
so Michael Pollan probably needs no
introduction to a Berkeley crowd but I
will introduce him nonetheless Michael
is an author who writes in his own words
about the places where nature and
culture intersect on our plates in our
farms and gardens and in our minds he's
the author of numerous New York Times
bestsellers including the botany of
desire and the Omnivore's Dilemma his
books have won a number of awards and
some have been adapted for television
and shown on Netflix and PBS in addition
to the awards for his books Michael has
won many other words really there's too
many to mention here but I will just
name two in 2009 he was named by
Newsweek as one of the top 10 new
thought leaders in 2010 he was named to
the time 100 which was the Time
magazine's annual list of the world's
100 most influential people in addition
to writing for the New York Times
Magazine Michaels Michael has written
extensively for The New Yorker Harper's
Magazine where he was executed editor
from 84 to 90 for National Geographic
Mother Jones New York Review of Books
woke among others and I'm not done
Michael
is currently the Lewis catch an arts
lecturer and professor of the practice
of nonfiction at Harvard and since 2003
he has held the John s and James Sheldon
I professor of journalism at UC
Berkeley's Graduate School of Journalism
and today here he is here to share with
us ideas that appear in his latest
bestseller his new book how to change
your mind what the new sign
of psychedelics teaches us about
consciousness dying addiction depression
and transcendence and and Michael will
talk about psychedelics I'm hoping from
a first-person perspective and and tell
us what that might in a what light that
might shed on the brains predictive
mechanisms Michael thank you new no no
no save it so I I got very interested in
in the predictive brain which I knew
nothing about when I started this
project I am so much my expertise is
like it's such a different level and it
can't believe I'm here with this group
so but I was trying to understand the
psychedelic experience and predictive
coding turns out to be one interesting
way into understanding that experience
now for me try and understand what is
this predictive brain not having the
benefit of listening to these lecturers
this this example which is the famous
example help me understand it so watch
this mask as it rotates and something
kind of interesting happens
so basically as that mass goes around it
goes from being convex to concave but
you saw how it popped out your brain
would not let you see a face as concave
for very long because faces aren't
you've learned from a very young age
probably while your parents were holding
you that faces are not concave and
there's an example where your brain is
overriding the information with a
prediction that it's so confident of and
I had heard that in the case of two
classes of people schizophrenic and
people tripping don't this doesn't
happen so and it's it's there's a lot of
literature about schizophrenia it's one
of the tests for schizophrenia so in
fact if you saw the back of that mask
and it didn't pop out see your doctor
but in the case of but I had I had heard
there's a researcher in Germany you've
done this research and and apparently
people who are tripping it also doesn't
pop out that they actually get a more
faithful version of reality so I thought
I should test this and as part of my
book I won't go into great detail but as
a as a responsible researcher I felt I
had to have a series of psychedelic
experiences and in one of them and this
was a high dose psilocybin trip
I brought my computer loaded with that
image into the treatment room and at
various points along the way I ran that
video the experiment experiment was a
disaster the first thing that happened
was that that imagery you saw that kind
of black and white computer-generated
imagery infected the whole experience
everything I saw I was in a black and
white video game it was just awful and
then I would stop and do this and
nothing happened and then finally when I
reached kind of the peak of the
experience and I had had my four grams
of mushrooms I did it again I was really
optimistic it was gonna happen and and
the thing turns and it just melted there
was no mask anymore so all of which is
to say it remains
I haven't proven to myself that this is
true but there is this German researcher
who's done this test and claims it's
it's true now the the collapse of priors
or the collapse of predictive coding it
may be about one of the values of
psychedelics to neuroscience and
computer science is that by disturbing a
system sometimes you can understand it
better and certainly psychedelics
disturb the system of the predictive
brain but not in a predictive way
oddly enough and I looked at this
question and talking to some
neuroscientists working on it in in
England and when your predictions break
down one of two things can happen one is
you actually get more information from
the world in a very raw state that isn't
being shaped by prediction like you can
see that the face is actually concave
and there are there are various examples
of kind of information whether it's
musical or visual coming through in a
more raw accurate state the doors of
perception is Huxley said have been open
wider but then there's another
phenomenon as all this data comes in the
mind is overwhelmed and what is that
what is it overwhelmed a mind
overwhelmed by data do generates new
predictions and they're really crazy so
you get this situation of seeing faces
in the rain or you patterns come out of
fields that don't actually have a
pattern because the brain is so eager to
restore visual prediction and oral
prediction and and that may explain
something that's going on with
hallucination that there is either too
much information or not enough
information as the brain just starts
projecting things it could be a paranoid
delusion too could be one of them one of
the interesting questions may be well
taken up later is at what scale can you
scale up predictive coding and the
predictive brain to other kinds of
stories some but you I think use the
word story that we're telling ourselves
a story with these predictions to other
things we're all kind of trapped in
narratives that we we use when we
enter a social situation like I can't
get through this dinner without a drink
right or I'm unworthy of love I'm
depressed I have this projection that I
put over the situation and it's
therefore I can't imagine there is love
coming toward me and you know I think
the model at the at the granular level
amoun talking about may apply up and one
of the one of the useful things about
psychedelics and why they're proven very
useful in therapy now is that they break
down those stories and give you a chance
to create new stories new predictions
about who you are what you need what
you're how you deal with social
situations and there was a very nice
metaphor that one of the neuroscientists
I interviewed a Dutch guy named Mendel
Kalin said that think of your brain as a
as a hill and your thoughts as sleds
going down that hill
the more of those sleds go down the hill
the deeper the grooves become and it
becomes at a certain point very
difficult to go down the hill without
getting drawn into the attractor of
those of those grooves and those groups
can be bad habits patterns of thought
assumptions about reality predictions
and as he put it the value of
psychedelics is metaphorically is that
they they're like a fresh snowfall that
fills all the grooves giving you the
freedom to bring your thoughts down on
another path so I found that was a very
helpful way to think about it so I'll
leave it there for now thank you very
much
so our next speaker is Professor
christos papadimitriou like I said
earlier he's just coming from New York
he's a professor of computer science at
Columbia University and one of the
world's leading computer science
theorists he is best known for his work
in computational complexity
he has also explored other fields
through what he calls the algorithmic
lens and has contributed to biology and
the theory of evolution economics and
game theory artificial intelligence
robotics and more recently the study of
the brain and then in his spare time he
has authored five textbooks and has
written three novels including one that
you would be familiar with here in logic
comics and his latest independence and
then when in other time that he has he
has taught at UC Berkeley for twenty
years and before that at Harvard MIT the
National Technical University of Athens
Stanford and UC San Diego Christo's has
been awarded the new prize Hydra please
John von Neumann medal the I Triple E
Computer Society Charles Babbage award
and the girdle prize
so Christo's please so I know they were
all thinking I thought that computer
scientists study the computer how come
this guy is going to speak about the
brain and you are you are right for the
longest time we have been studying the
computer we were obsessed with a couple
I was obsessed with a computer we were
so obsessed with a computer that we
named our discipline after it okay but
but about 25 years ago something
happened the internet was here and as a
result that was it that was a liberating
moment okay we looked at each other and
we said we don't have to start with a
computer and so we we studied the
universe okay really I mean also so this
is what this is what we have been
thinking ever since I mean oh and and
basically very the reason is this okay
that that you have learned a few things
we have developed a craft a new a new
way of thinking that is different and
what what what happens is that when you
study another problem you know so you
know there are there are computer
scientists now who are doing in this
room who are doing a quantum theory
statistical physics biology and
evolution socio-economic and Sciences
and ultimately the brain and I mean oh
how do you do this basically it was a
liberating moment like like what
happened in the 17th century light needs
and Newton told mathematicians it's not
the triangles and the circles you're
stupid ok it's it's it's it's the
universe ok you can use you are craft to
study everything and the trick is for in
the computer science world is that you
close your eyes and you try to find the
size that the scientific object you are
dealing with beat the market the cell
bunch of particles the brain that this
object is trying to compute something ok
then something interesting things happen
often not always not even so and this is
incidentally this is please a huge part
of you know as a chakra told us a huge
part of the mission of and so ultimately
I arrived at the brain and studying the
brain entails getting this book ok so
this is this is this is something
between the faculty in a Bible
ok so it's it's a and basically it
actually is reprinted every five years
and it gets 200 page
and everything about these principles of
sort of neuroscience and principles
should not grow right now when when they
went agreed when the Greeks decided to
find the principles that entail or
mathematics invent they came up with
four lines and and you know the fact is
that despite the amazing explosion in
experimental data and even insights into
the brain we are no closer to basically
solving the ultimate question which the
overarching question being how does the
brain brain beget the mind okay so you
know let me let me in the in the words
of one of my heroes in this epoch we do
not have a logic for the transformation
of neural activity into thought and
action okay so and frankly this is a
very challenging thing okay that because
this man which are the actual things
that this is what you should all be
working on and I'm asking you okay and I
hope that this that that with these
narratives or short narrative I'll give
you an example of what I mean by this
story of how computer scientists can
offer something in this in this endeavor
and and so what what do you think what
would be such a such a formal system and
I'll tell you about an idea I have we
have
the other computer scientists the US
scientists both got math Sanders and
Paula Mike codings a linguist at
Columbia done in Tripoli my student so
here is here's their idea
first of all let's let's watch the scope
people who spoke before me exclusively
talking about perception okay so let's
decide that perception is in good hands
okay you know and and see what else is
there okay so what you purport you
perceive eventually become something
else okay and starts having an
interesting inner life and we know much
much less about this inner life than we
know about how it how it gets there okay
and I'm proposing let's let's
concentrate on that I mean oh how do we
do the good things perceiving things and
it turns out that so what is the
mechanism
I mean know is we know it's neurons okay
we know it's molecules but I mean what
is it really is there another level at
which you can describe it and what idea
is that babe it's Assemblies of neurons
okay an assemblage of neurons that's all
that's old news there are populations of
neurons maybe a few tens of thousands
imprinting in the brain a memory a
concept an ID a story and so on so
people you know we knew that these
things existed and actually we suspected
it for a long time it has been
conjectured six of seventy years ago but
now 15 years ago we saw them through
calcium imaging and so this is odd news
so our idea is that is that these things
have operations origami no so and they
protein and we know that these things
happen okay but but so no we put them
together and decided to start studying
as a whole they project for one brain
area to another
when when they require wondering when
when they realize that with currents of
the steam of islami stimuli they they
sort of they start intersecting more
neurons migrate from that of the other
they pattern complete ok so you know if
you if if if if just just one of them is
a little stimulated maybe it's going to
complete and remember the whole thing
and most importantly in humans they can
merge okay so merging is something that
linguists have blonde thought that was
around we have been observing it in the
brain in the last thing years and we now
know know how to do it okay that what I
mean that you know these operations we
have there two things right I mean first
of all we don't pull them out out of
thin air I mean oh there are experiments
that are best explained by assuming that
the simply do these operations and
number two we know the kind they can
happen in the brain you have simulations
we have mathematical theorems that show
that these things happen and of these
operations marriage is by far the most
complicated it requires a lot of
plasticity a lot of synaptic
connectivity and the coordination of
five brain areas and it seems plausible
but only we have it okay but this is
something that is exclusively human so I
guess what what I'm telling you is that
is that there is a variance to believe
that these operations may and the life
that higher cognitive functions of the
human brain such as language listening
and so on okay so in fact we have we
have a proposed brain architecture but
that implements syntax in language okay
so
more than more than have a you know
hundred thirty years ago
the two founders of neuroscience so this
picture okay so you know they you know
and and they saw two different things in
it
Camillo Golgi saw the whole thing and
admire did as a complex and fascinating
network and said this is the network
this network is what you should be
studying and that's good that's called a
reticule ism okay so so in contrast a
Ramana canal sold so this picture and
and looked at this this pyramid of blood
in green in the green circle and said
this is the neuron folks and we should
spend the next century studying it
because the brain is made from the new
okay and they were both right of course
okay they were both wrong of rejecting
the other point of view you know they
had an epic fight at Stockholm we both
don't want the Nobel Prize but and but
in some sense the Rahman Qahhar was the
right one because there was an army of
scientists ready to study the neuron and
not to study the network and the network
basically we started studying it seventy
years later so you know in the world
work of who bellavita
so I guess what I'm saying is is there
is maybe a third intermediate wait so
you know that but that this is this may
be an interesting level two thank you
very much
so we're running a little bit behind
time about half an hour so I think what
I'll do is start off the Q&A sessions
with some questions that I have and then
if you also welcome to ask questions of
each other but one big question that
pops up in my head is how much concrete
evidence is there for the predictive
brain hypothesis so I think the field is
slowly chipping away at it and starting
to do experiments along these lines so
one is just you know for a long time
people have tried to tease apart the
effect of these top-down connections so
that diagram that I showed you these
connections between brain areas are
almost two-way so there's information
flowing from low levels to higher levels
and there's information flowing back
from the higher levels containing more
abstract information back to the lower
levels more related to the data coming
in and so typically that's been done by
cooling the higher areas and then
looking at it as effect on the lowest or
areas or knocking it out somehow and
sort of teasing it apart but the effects
did sort of measurements they've gotten
from that or kind of inconclusive
because they they typically use very
similar simple stimuli like a sine wave
grading or a bar or a spot of light and
so I think from my point of view in
terms of these hypotheses the stimuli
they've been using those experiments are
simply too simple to reveal anything so
you have to sort of get like a cow
on there or something like that that
kind of image I mean what you want to do
is put the cow on and then say okay if I
knock out this higher-level
area then what changes in the
lower-level area we would expect all
kinds of effects and so I think we we
now have the technology potentially to
do those kind of experiments you know
using calcium imaging and other other
methodologies in more detail so but it's
we have sort of some findings from fMRI
that are consistent with this idea of
higher levels affecting lower-level
areas but we really want to get there in
there at the more detailed level looking
at individual in the wrongs and see
what's happening but it's definitely
possible so let's do you have anything
so much I don't know where to I was like
weird the the the idea that predictions
drive not just infant behavior but also
behavior throughout childhood at
multiple levels is pretty robust to us
like the my lab works a lot on how
expectations and predictions about where
we're you're best off learning how that
impacts attention we have other studies
where instead of it being an
informational reward it's something like
stickers and in a kid gambling task kids
are good at generating expectations
about where they will get the most
stickers when that varies
probabilistically that can be explained
in terms of them generating predictions
about what the payout is of a particular
choice there's there's an interesting
set of evidence I think also from from
eyewitness testimony and places where
memory fails so it's like there's some
work by people like preneur lab or no
hammer at Rutgers that shows that when
you show somebody a scene of something
very common so for example a picture of
a kitchen what people feel like they're
getting out of that is a very rich
representation they feel like they're
looking around and with high fidelity
encoding what they see but you take the
picture away and you ask something like
what color was the refrigerator house
like and people will say it was silver
when there actually was no refrigerator
I mean the photo at all things that are
very common that you highly expect to be
there it guides your attention away from
those you don't need to check those out
if you're pretty sure they're gonna be
there I mean stay you should be looking
at the things that are not in all
kitchens that prediction is so strong
that you don't notice when the
refrigerator is missing you really feel
like you saw a civil refrigerator and
that's funny in a psych experiment it's
less funny when it's eyewitness
testimony
Michael I have a have a question for you
you know when when you're tripping did
you did you wear eye shades and what
happened then if I did in the guy so I
was trying to simulate the kind of
research that's going on at universities
testing psilocybin on people as a
therapy and also to see whether you what
other effects it has at various doses
but I couldn't get into those trials so
I did it with an underground therapist
so called and we tried to imitate the
the what they were doing and and one of
the things they do which I found very
interesting and curious is that you wear
eye shades during the experience and
listen to music on headphones and the
idea is to to make you go inside instead
of the recreational psychedelic
experience which is very much about
experience there's all this incredible
sensory information coming in and out
your brain processes that are missed
process it when you wear eye shades not
only does it tend to become a more kind
of inward psychoanalytic experience but
you see things your your your mind
doesn't tolerate the lack of information
coming in and starts generating images
and this happens in isolation tanks to
float tanks where if you remove all the
data coming in to all our senses the the
brain will begin to produce stories it's
just kind of compulsive about it or
making order given the invitation of no
data and so that that's a very striking
and the change from wearing the eye
shades to taking them off completely
changes your reality so it is about
prediction in a sense your mind is
making predictions based on very limited
information one of the things we haven't
talked about though is that in this
model there's a there's a reality is
continually correcting right yes the
predictions right there's there's I mean
when you talk about top-down and
bottom-up you're generating a prediction
and then you're getting some data to
confirm you in
otherwise we would all be seeing a
different world and and I think that's
something that goes wrong and and I
really think you should think about
psychedelics as a way to test these I
think it has enormous potential as a
probe of this very process I don't think
I'm gonna be able to get giving
psychedelics to baby so I like the idea
well as your colleague Alison Gopnik
says the babies are already trippin she
thinks all kids are trippin till about
four or five yeah in a very precise
sense that they're that they don't have
well-developed priors and that there are
predictions and so they're taking in
information in a very different way and
and and and therefore willing to
literally think outside the box because
they don't have models which makes them
better better performers at certain
kinds of games than adults are because
they're not bound by the solution that
worked well last time at that point I
think is a really is a really important
one and also a very interesting one and
one of the things that make studying
children so interesting if you don't
have concepts for things like if you
don't know what's likely and what's not
once you realize that those concepts are
driving your predictions about the world
it's like it becomes easier to
understand why kids sometimes expect
things like monsters yes when that's not
something that they don't perceive so
it's like once he knows that perception
is noisy yeah kids having no concepts
and trying to make sense of the world
it's like I completely agree with
Allison that's like it's it's it's it's
akin to kids kids tripping is I think he
put it christos so I I wanted to
understand from you based on all that
we've been discussing so far you know
the advances that are going on in
machine learning and deep learning do
you see connections between what
neuroscientists are saying about how the
brain works and the advances that are
happening in learning of course of
course that varies
at SARM leather there is there is some
photo logical convergence I see more and
more neuroscientists when they try to
find out how a system works looking back
and saying let's see what what an
artificial system would evolve you know
by by by traffic trying to do to do the
same task ok to England and compare you
know come they come the distinctions and
so this is this is now I think an
emerging major MRI time you know that
that that major methodology you know you
know we saw it in during the segment of
but you see it now everyone you know
especially the younger things things if
these deep learning models are missing
from the biology is the feedback
connections so they typically have just
like a feed-forward flow of information
and so I think that's a very rich area
to explore now is trying to get that
kind of sort of top-down inference in
there and a sense what you want is these
deep learning machines to hallucinate
you know like we do and I think there
are newer scientists I mentioned to you
and I'll say it I think they have in
their lab some examples of imagery that
is pure hallucination I have seen
you know there is there is there's
somebody that who uses the dream stuff
yeah that's kind of so I think before we
open up the Florida questions from the
audience I just wanted to make another
point about this whole idea of it might
seem rather esoteric but when I was
working on my book the man who wasn't
there which is about a series of
neuropsychological conditions that
disturb our sense of self one of the
themes that emerged as I was looking at
various conditions is the idea of the
predictive brain and how this framework
of thinking about what what we are who
we are has a prediction starts giving us
insights into how certain people might
be experiencing their condition if you
take for example schizophrenia the first
trying symptoms of schizophrenia involve
things like hearing voices in your head
that seem alien
like somebody else's voices you can have
thoughts in your head that feel again
like somebody else's thoughts you also
have this sensation of losing control of
your own actions you you you might be
like for instance if I were to pick up
this glass of water I have an implicit
sensation of being the agent of my
actions I have the sensation that I am
doing it it's not even a thought in my
head it's just that's how it feels
but with for someone with schizophrenia
that very act might feel like that they
haven't willed it so it will feel like
somebody else is directing their actions
and there is a way in which the
predictive brain framework can be used
to understand what's happening so like
even the sense of agency that we all
implicitly will we take for granted
seems to be a product of the predictive
brain where if my brain is sending you
know commands to my muscles to pick up
the glass of water it's also sending a
copy of the same commands to other parts
of the brain the other parts of the
brain are then making a prediction about
the sensory consequences of that action
and when the sensory consequences of the
action the predicted consequences match
the actual sensory input that has
implicitly tagged as an
action that I did so it just feels like
my action but you can imagine in this
whole complicated process somewhere
something goes RI and the predicted
consequences don't match the actual
sensory input and you end up with a loss
of sense of agency and you can you can
have the sensation that you're doing
something but you're not willing it and
that then you know leads to downstream
consequences like you kid this can
happen with thoughts in your head this
can happen with voices in your head and
then eventually all of these will have
downstream consequences or paranoid
delusions and so again this this is not
just a theoretical thing this has this
way of thinking has a real impact on
understanding how people are suffering
because of some of these conditions
including depersonalization disorder
autism there's a whole range of things
that can be understood to some degree
not not entirely but to some degree by
using this framework of the predictive
brain so shall be open welcome you know
the semester at the same assisity
there was a little a little thread of
commutation of Psychiatry and then I was
very surprised to see that you know how
they would phrase all kinds of psychosis
as as failures of Basel okay there are
no different kinds of a you know so one
last thing about this whole predictive
brain thing one of the most astounding
outcomes of thinking about this way is
that each one of us right now is
experiencing being somebody right you're
sitting in your chair you're
experiencing everything the brain has
the same mechanisms for creating your
sense of self as it has for creating
perceptions of something coming from
outside so you at this point might be
your brains best prediction of all the
inputs that are coming from outside and
from inside your body so we are all
predictions and sometimes those
predictions go wrong and yeah we'll
leave it at that
we'll we'll take questions so if people
raise their hands will have the mics
going out
so drew we can start a bit oh sorry hi
yeah I think that the distinction that
you made at the beginning between no
does a brain may take bottom-up inputs
and then you know works from there or
there's a brain make inferences from
above I that's kind of an artificial
distinction I think because both are
happening all the time I mean reality is
what goes away when you don't want it
even when you don't want it to so I mean
the input from the senses is constantly
interacting with the mechanism that's in
the brain which is not a formal
inference mechanism it's a it's a series
of statistical co-occurrences among the
neurons and so you know the fact that it
can mimic logical and inferential
behavior yeah oh sure that's good that's
good for us but it also can do not
logically not behavior that's why we
have Donald Trump so so you know I think
it's more fruitful to look at it as an
interaction between the sensory
information coming in and you know what
what sort of statistical regularities
we've learned and and I kind of agree
with Daniel Dennett is that what we call
consciousness is kind of an epiphenomena
of that interaction and it is not
actually integral to it
so that seems right I was like I was
like that seems like it's both top-down
and bottom-up I don't know are there
people that don't think that high well
let's see I think I think it's a fair
distinction in terms of the history of
the field right right right yeah if you
just look at how like the evolution of
neuroscience and how things happened I
think there was definitely in the
beginning a movement where people
thought of neurons as feature detectors
right right the neurons sort of
detecting a feature here and then it
passes on its feature to the next level
and then it accumulates that sends that
feature the next level and so that's
high Hubel and Wiesel is hierarchical
model right right was a sort of strictly
feed-forward flow and I think it just
wasn't you know in the 60s and so forth
when they were thinking about these
things it just wasn't on the radar
screen that how much you actually have
to infer things and it was actually in
part through the early efforts in
computer vision in the 1960s were you
know at first I thought it was going to
be very simple you just hook up the
camera to the computer and then do some
logic and it's going to work and they
realized that even the problem of you
know finding the edges the contours of
an object in the image was extremely
difficult and how much that relied upon
high-level knowledge to interpret that
and that was maybe the beginnings and
it's still a kind of a relative but I
think it's slowly you know people now
more or less think of it that way I
don't think it's so much I it's not
friction about that high level no I
think it's now it's just more matter of
like the nuts and bolts of how does that
actually work how would you design an
experiment that tease it apart and so
forth well how does it change across
context it's like even within the same
task depending upon the information you
have available loss like you may be
using more bottom-up or top-down after
all this is probabilistic so yeah I
think that's not a contentious point
I'll be great
so
from their plating the striped t-shirt
hi so I have two questions the first
ones for a professor kid and that comes
to when adults are learning foreign
languages and we have I find because I'm
currently learning my boyfriend's
language Norwegian and I find it very
difficult when I'm hearing Norwegians
speak it really just sounds like a giant
amalgamation of sound them no idea
so has anyone done any research on how
if there is since our brains are so much
more advanced now is there any different
way that we do this compared to when
babies are learning their first language
and my second question is to just
generally when it comes to bias since
there seems like there's a predictive
element in that has anyone studied how
how the predictive brain plays a role in
the biases that we that we carry and how
we use that to judge people or
situations thank you so for that first
question there's all sorts of cues
besides just the statistics of the
syllables that we know are used in
parsing a continuous speech stream into
the words that's a great example it's
very hard to pull out just one word for
a language that you don't have a lot of
experience with there's cues like one of
the ones that we studied in my lab that
maybe this will actually be helpful
we know babies pick up on it but once
you're in adults that has another
language as like it's hard to go back
and reott end to the low-level stuff
like statistics between the syllables
speech disfluencies
are universal so sounds like uh um and
they always occur before our word
particularly before words that are not
very predictable so if I'm talking it
would be very unlikely that I would say
could you hand me the cup that's a
pretty easy word to say for something
like monitor that's less frequent it's
more likely that an eye is going to
refer to a weird thing so if you're
listening to your boyfriend talk and you
hear an uh it's like babies pay
attention
you can pay attention to you have at
least one half of the word there I was
like that's that's a sign that it's a
word boundary and those Allston occur at
the end of a sentence so there's a tip
in terms of that was at feel like that's
a question that could be like its own
session um there's all kinds of
differences between how an infant
approaches language and an adult and it
likely has to do with your expectations
and also your abilities as like as an
adult when I travel to a foreign country
one of the first things that struck me
the first time I did it is how little
language I actually need because I have
the adult ability to point and use
pragmatics to convey what I need where
an infant who cannot move or even like
not hit themselves in the face with the
rattle is way more dependence on adults
they really need language to get what
they want so there there is no
experiment the experiment you want is
making an adult both cute but also as
dependence on other people without motor
and pragmatics abilities like if you did
that uh and then they still couldn't
learn language that would tell you
something about fern plasticity but
given that it's really hard to come up
with an ethical set up to make that
happen we don't know the second part of
the question about biases anyone wanted
so you know apparently the thesis here
is that the brain is good at predicting
at the neuron level okay you know you
know if you go to the macro level you
know I think I think as species we are
remarkably remarkably bad at predicting
okay so and and or arguing
probabilistically arguing you know if
anybody you know I know how many of you
have tried to teach students probability
is the hardest subject okay especially
Bayes rule okay so so it's I think we
are we are we are very very bad
at the at the macro-level
okay so you know and and it could be
that we are have been selected for that
right I mean no because you don't forget
so no if you are here it means that
three thousand or a few thousands of our
ancestors decided to do something really
stupid so not to leave the village where
they are so you know and then cross the
mountains for the next Valley okay so
that's so they were probably I mean we
are with seemingly wired for making
short-term predictions well but long
term
I mean climate change is one obvious
thing where we're completely losing the
plot so from the very beginning so I
want to thank the panelists for a very
stimulating discussion so it seems like
you know humans and babies are very
adept at learning to classify objects
using just a few examples where as kind
of state of the art deep learning
techniques might require hundreds of
thousands or millions of labeled
examples before they can effectively
classify at the same level or accuracy
or something close to that
so can biology or know of science kind
of shed light on how we might you know
use how you know methodologies that
humans might use for learning and kind
of imbue those and kind of deep learning
or machine learning
christos I I happen to be a little
skeptical as to you know i I've also
studied evolution in other life I mean
also and
and you know the very our brain has
evolved okay you know it had very very
very poor materials to evolve from okay
so so you know it and and and whatever
corner of the possibilities it ended up
so you know it's not likely to be
optimal so you know you know in other
words I don't think that that that
they're going to be major major insights
that I will be useful for for
computation but that come from the way
the way the brain works and I mean oh
the as you probably know very well what
the artificial neural the way they work
has you know my relates a lot of the
ways of the actual neurons what's that
for example the hierarchy that Brunel
showed us works so I you know these days
when you write when you write a research
proposal about the brain you are almost
obliged to say that maybe some of these
lessons will be
one day to build better computer systems
okay so you know but I always do it one
thing we can incorporate from biology I
think on this is that the brain is
constantly learning at all time scales
so from adaptation that occurs on the
order of seconds to learning things over
your lifetime and these are biophysical
processes that occur in the brain that
changes the plasticity that we knew wait
has happening all these different time
scales and one of the sort of challenges
that are creeping in now to machine
learning and deep learning is the
problem what they call stationarity so
typically when people train their
algorithms they sort of have a big data
set like a batch and then just train it
on this big batch and it'll learns about
apples or whatever and then now if you
want to learn something else you have to
sort of give it a new batch of data when
that was going to forget the old batch
and so how do you keep the Neuse the old
stuff that you learned around while
still learning new stuff and so this is
the per something the brain excels at
and consumed adapt and learn stuff over
over a lifetime without forgetting
things and so I think that you know and
sort of gleaning something from these
different time scales and putting those
into the networks I think what about
about the the data sets that are used I
think is something that also is changing
I was like I think when people first
started using the the the term child
inspired AI they had that same sort of
intuition you did kids can learn things
relatively quickly from just a few
instances we have the internet now with
all sorts of everything on google images
like surely we can do at least as well
as a kid there's a new appreciation that
I'm hearing a knowledge more in just the
past few years which is the type of data
it's not just the amount that you have
it's it's what you have and if you think
about a kid going around the world they
have the ability to elicit stuff that
Google images if you're training a model
I was like you hey you have what's there
and that's it kids have the ability to
be cute and get more evidence that's one
major thing going for them but then also
if you think about every time they place
their eye on something and they fixate
something each moment is another piece
of data think about what just those
images look like what's on their visual
field that's very different that's
that's much richer than what's available
on google images so IIIi would expect
that there's going to be a shift to stop
thinking about kids as smart inferences
from smaller data sets so it's like they
definitely can do that in ways that I
think my google home could learn from my
two-and-a-half year old is only two and
a half and is better at answering
questions than the Google home there's
something to that
but I think there also is going to be a
shift towards appreciating exactly how
much data two-and-a-half-year-old has
and that it's a different type
qualitatively in quantitatively from
from from what we have been using to
train these models we have time for one
more question so we'll go right out
there the gentleman in the yellow black
check shirt at a question about thinking
about the brain and formal systems and
so especially for thinking about the
human brain versus other brains and
thinking about how there might be
operations that are unique to the human
brain how do you think about those
operations is stemming from some
physical thing within the brain that is
president human brains and not in a
mouse brain or fly training or what have
you
thank you I understand so in particular
I spoke about this this this complicated
operation called the merge something
that Chomsky had predicted in the
sixties and now we get some evidence
from experiments that marriage does
happen in the brain
in connection to language and so on the
basis of very flimsy evidence and so you
know I venture to conjecture that but
that marriage is something that is
exclusive to humans and here is here is
the only evidence that I have right I
mean know that there is very very say a
neural superhighways or you know a very
very important fiber in connecting
essentially the superior temporal gyrus
with refer neural cortex and these it's
called are quite a vesicles and this is
the only place where there is left-right
symmetry lateralization anatomical earth
organization in the mammalian brain and
it it pertains to the circuits that we
believe have believed for for almost 150
years that have to do with language okay
with syntax in particular it goes from
the place where words we seem to seem to
be dealt with to the place where
sentences and phrases seem to be dealt
with so that's this is this you know
this is the you asked me about the
anatomical difference okay this is
something that we know but very very
something that I just add something to
another another network in the brain
that doesn't appear and it doesn't
appear to be in animals that the default
mode network which is partly implicated
in that and and that this is a set of
tightly linked structures in the midline
that connect the cortex to older deeper
areas of memory and emotion and is
involved in generating the sense of self
that's where self reflection takes place
time travel a lot of higher
metacognitive processes and it's
interesting when that goes offline as it
does during psychedelic experience or
high-dose cycle it's
experience you experience the loss of a
sense of self there's this sense that
yourself merges into something larger
[Music]
the first when they've started imaging
brains of people on psilocybin in LSD
they really expected to see an explosion
of activity all over the brain they were
very surprised to see the default mode
Network was down was down regulated
dramatically in effect it's also
observed during meditation if you put a
very experienced meditator in a in an
fMRI that part of the brain will also go
quiet so so that that kind of sense of a
self of an ego may be something that it
we don't share and the default mode
Network I believe doesn't develop in
children until you know prelate and
development till about four to six or
something there's like oh yeah I was
like that that's consistent with what
would I
so I'm not sure about that but that's
like that the kids are not good at
representing themselves as people in
time and space jam and also really bad
at representing other people sorry it's
also interesting that I me know what you
said about that also the apparatus that
I talked about that whatever security is
apparently is myelinated during the 20th
month of the hood light which is exactly
when there's also a very intriguing
condition called cotard's syndrome where
people who have that condition think
that they're dead so they really believe
that they don't exist
and the default mode network again gets
implicated in that it's depressed the
activity in the default mode network is
depressed down to the levels that you
would see in people with extreme
depression so so something about the
default mode network which is involved
in creating your like you said your
sense of self in quartered syndrome
that's not activity is diminished
tremendously
and evidence that but when a large group
of people attend maybe see a movie or
maybe even a lecture their default mode
synchronize so I can feel that right now
so unfortunately we have run out of time
I think we can keep going with this for
a long time
questions are such but thank you very
much for coming
[Applause]